[موسيقى]
كان يقارن باسحاق نيوتن مايكل عطيه عالم
لبناني في الهندسه والرياضيات واحد ابرز
علماء الرياضيات في العالم
ولد في العام
1929 لابن لبناني وهم اسكتلنديه
عاش طفولته في السودان مع عائلته ودرس
الابتدائيه في مدارس القاهره والخرطوم
درس المرحله الثانويه في كليه فيكتوريا ثم
تخرج دكتورا في الرياضيات عام
1954 من جامعه ترينتي في كامبريدج
بريطانيا
شغل عطيه منصب زميل باحث ومحاضر مساعد في
جامعه ثم عمل محاضرا جمعيا وزميلا تعليميا
في كليه ثم انتقل الى جامعه اخرى
شغل منصب رئيس جمعيه لندن للرياضيات لمده
عامين وكان رئيسا لمؤتمرات بوغواش للعلوم
والشؤون العالميه من عام
1997 حتى عام 2002
كما اسمى في تاسيس فريق انترا اكاديمي
المعني بالقضايا الدوليه ورابطه
الاكاديميات الاوروبيه والجمعيه الرياضيه
الاوروبيه
شارك في انشاء معهد اسحاق نيوتن للعلوم
الرياضيه في كامبريدج وكان اول مدير له
كما شغل العديد من المناصب العلميه في
بريطانيا
ابرز الجوائز التي حصل عليها لقب فارس
البريطاني وجازه ابل وجازت الملك فيصل
العالميه ووسام وفيلد ووسام كوبلي
توفي عام 2019 في ادمرا
[موسيقى]